man's world what's up buddy
not much Rich how are you good what do
you got for me today
what is your thoughts on future online
dating where do you think it's going to
go
how would How would how can a man
connect with a woman what's what's your
theory well you're asking different
questions you're asking the future and
you're asking how do you connect with a
woman today so which one do you want to
hit on or do you want to do both let's
go online online Future dating
online dating is
going to like your success on it is
going to be determined on generally
speaking the first photograph that they
see
so if you don't have good photography
you're wasting your time so that's the
first thing
okay
um most guys have [ __ ] photographs I
mean I like I've sat there with women
and they're like oh my dating app
whatever I'm like you know pass me your
phone let me see your matches you know
some sort of thing or let's go through
your phone together right and it's like
your competition for the most part sucks
if you got the gig down right I mean I
talk about it in my book like in the
chapter on how to use dating apps
properly it's it's always bizarre to me
that people can't spend a few hundred
dollars put on a nice outfit you know
get a nice tailored shirt go on location
with a couple of different outfits
change you know get some shots like get
some good photography because that's
going to make the biggest difference in
your success online right beyond that if
you're not at least a seven or eight out
of ten on your own scale with 10 being
the best version yourself like
a lot of guys will be like I'm a two I'm
a three I'm a four I'm a five you're
gonna get the worst results possible
you're not going to get any matches and
if you do get matches you're going to
get the worst looking checks you've ever
seen that are way below you so your best
Roi your return on investment if you
want to get good results is going to be
make sure you're at least a seven or
eight out of ten yourself and you have a
very good photograph for your number one
photograph the other ones should be good
too but the first photograph they see
matters the most because a lot of the
times they'll look at that and they
don't even look at the bio they don't
look at the other photographs it's just
a right or left very quickly so if you
want to get that match you have to get
their attention with the first
photograph it's got to be good
so what do you think it's going to be
like in 2032
you know
there was a company that I almost
invested in about 15 years ago because
online dating came around
I think 2001 2002 for me lava life lime
was it LimeWire or Limelight I don't
know
um Plenty of Fish you know been around
for a long time that's not that site
skyrocketed and there was talk of video
okay now they have an integrated video
into
dating apps yet but I think it's going
to come because right now it's just
static photography
um video is very popular with Tick Tock
short form video Tick Tock Instagram
reels uh YouTube shorts It's watched way
more than long form content today so
it's only a matter of time before
somebody's gonna cook up a dating app
where it's going to be like a three or a
five second video and you're gonna have
to dance like a [ __ ] monkey or
something and she's gonna do some hair
flip or something like that to get your
attention yeah there'll probably be some
integration uh somebody mentioned here
in the chat like metaverse VR might
might come your way that's going to get
catfishing to some new levels of [ __ ]
right yeah you know if that comes but
video is going to be hard to see
people like video content but the
problem with with video content is as
hard to catfish and women like to
catfish they'll use older photography
they'll use touch-up filters and that's
harder to do with the video so yes the
adoption rate for women will probably go
down the adoption rate for guys will
probably like guys will jump through any
Hoops that they give them you know jump
how high you know jump in what direction
sure you know they'll do anything to get
women especially if they don't have
women in their life right so if they
have to make videos and jump around like
a monkey they'll probably do it so
that's probably what you'll see coming
up in the future but again I mean it's
all going to boil down to can you get
their attention in a noisy world because
they're distracted by notifications by
tick tocks by this that and the other
thing can you get their attention very
quickly with one great photograph if you
can nail that you'll do very well in
dating apps yeah okay
um I mean that's all I wanted to ask you
what what your theory is on the future
of dating
um now really it's um you know I I'm
thinking in my head the theory is that
it's going to be a video message like 30
seconds long you introduce yourself and
it's actually 30 seconds it'll probably
be like less than 10 seconds because
women have no patience for any of that
so let's say 10 seconds and then if they
like it they go into your profile
they'll see another introduction video
and then from there instead of texting
you they'll just basically call you no
texting no photos no nothing sorry I
didn't I didn't finish what I wanted to
get out about that 2003 story so I was
talking to the guy one of the senior
Executives from lava life
um I got introduced from my account
because I was going to invest into this
uh dating app at the time and I thought
that the most popular or the most used
dating apps were like photographs like
profiles we didn't have yeah phone apps
back then because that was 2003 like
phones didn't come out to 2008. so it
was all browser-based it was all like
website based right so you'd upload a
picture you type in your your bio your
height what you like to do long walks on
the beach and all that [ __ ] stuff
and the guy told me something which I
thought was shocking you know at the
time he goes the vast majority of users
at that time back then were calling it
was it was called all in hotlines like
you would call in and you would have
like chat rooms or like a chat room with
two people or like a bunch of people
that's where they made most of the money
and that's where their volume was it
wasn't for browser-based photography
uploads so yeah and that was because it
was very easy for women to convince men
to take them out based on their
personality right yeah okay because guys
will fall in love with the chick's
personality and they'll create this
image in their head or what they're
looked at so that was how they can't
fish back then and then it moved to
still photography which moved to dating
apps with just swiping left and right so
I think it's a matter of time before it
moves to video format just based on
those past runs but we'll see what
happens
do you think that Western women would go
for something like that
if it makes it harder for them to
catfish probably not because women see
men and women lie differently on dating
apps men lie about how successful they
are and how tall they are generally
speaking women lie about how beautiful
they are and how youthful they are
that's why they use older pictures with
filters or if they use photography if
they're overweight they only film from
here up from like elevated angle sort of
thing right so yeah men and women lie
differently so they have to figure out a
way to integrate video but still let
women deceive men the way that they've
always deceived that for them to adopt
it do you think they'll lose money
because of of the video no because
thirst is endless and women love
attention women want attention men have
thirsts for women so
as long as somebody connects those two
together properly then they'll make
they'll make money
so they'll still make profit from it
yeah so there's lots of money in dating
apps right
yeah I know that you were trying to get
into it and and you were trying to get
into the video side of it and uh it
never happened for you no it was too
early it was too early and I think it's
still too early today I don't think
you're gonna see it for a few more years
yeah all right that's all I wanted to
ask you rich thank you all right man
where are you at by the way thank you I
see you got some uh I am actually
I'm in Coffs Harbor
um I've got a massive
this is not my place I'm just uh sharing
it
Australia New South Wales New South
Wales very nice and I've just I started
my own little podcast show as well and
um this is where I would normally do it
as well I'd like to interview women try
to find out what's going on with their
side of the story when it comes to
dating as well and
try to help women try to find out try to
get them to trust men somehow if you
know what I'm trying to say on the first
date it's you're in for an uphill battle
man like the only time I see guys
talking to women and women listening to
guys Matthew Hussey is probably the most
successful guy at it
and um you know if you look at his
videos on YouTube he's got rooms filled
with yeah fours they're not attractive
they're well past their Prime and right
he's basically telling them what guys
want and all they're doing is they're
just drooling over this hot Australian
guy
yeah right yeah I'm not going for
anything like that it's just basically
um I've noticed that women don't just
give out their numbers they they
okay
the honesty on the men's side
they have lost complete trust in men
because they they don't they just don't
believe them anymore well they've been
told for years not to trust men and that
men are evil right and that the
patriarchy oppresses them and you know
feminism and all that sort of stuff so
the only way that you're going to get a
woman's attention today is if you're
high value I mean if you want to have
the attention of a lot of beautiful
women that are gonna like be fun for you
to be around you've got to be a high
value guy that's why I say Chase
Excellence not women like put your dent
in the universe make money make sure you
max out on your looks in your game don't
be fat be captivating have interesting
hobbies like these are the main things
that guys have to get through their head
right
um yeah of course there's a whole like
looks money status sort of thing but it
goes well beyond that I mean you can
have looks money and status and be
boring as [ __ ] yeah and the chick's not
going to be into you right like if you
don't have any interesting hobbies if
you have nothing to invite her into to
go and do she's not going to want
anything to do with you right so
captivation is huge but nobody ever
really talks about that and that's what
I was talking about the theory of uh
video chat instead of texting instantly
to get that woman's attention so that
you can get that Honesty somehow some
kind of honesty I know I get it right
now they they um I mean they do any kind
of
connecting outside of the app it's
usually with a phone call they don't
usually use video
women don't give out their phone their
phone numbers I've interviewed a couple
of girls they gave they gave out their
numbers to a guy after a week of talking
to them on Tinder the first thing they
got was a [ __ ] dick Pig
that's the first thing that they got no
[ __ ] and this is what I'm saying it's
awful yeah guys don't have a lot of game
too right like they don't they don't
understand the metrics they think
they're just whipping it out is going to
get girls to fall over them and it's
like look maybe if you're Giga Chad that
might work but for the vast majority of
guys whipping it out ain't gonna get you
anything
yeah anyway all right rich thank you for
your time mate thank you all right see
you buddy take care uh yeah Ernesto says
being boring basically limits you to
female accountants like yeah if you know
if you're dating Bean counters lawyers
doctors like any of these professional
designation type of checks if you're
boring you might do well because all
they're really doing is they're into
their 30s they've got their designation
it's raining on the wall in Mahogany and
they're looking for like the right guy
to get you know married to sort of thing
and if you have a good income
you can be boring but you're not going
to have her best you know I can promise
you that hey guys I really hope that you
enjoyed that short clip if you did
consider supporting the creation of
content by checking out my supplement
line pinned in the top comment below of
this video in the comments there's a
link to the unpluggedalpha.com forward
slash shop when you click through you'll
be able to land over here and the entire
lineup is broken down by category that
it performs best in estrogen metabolism
fat burning your foundational Essentials
for health immune Health performance and
testosterone support if you check out
with coupon code Alpha 10 you'll get 10
off on your first order there's also the
option to use the Subscribe and save
model or regular shipments will be sent
over to you on a regular basis and that
gives you a little bit of a discount and
your supplement facts are always broken
down over here thanks for watching I
hope you guys have an awesome day and
again check out that link it's pinned in
the top comment below in this video
peace out